hello very good evening thanks for  joining us and we start with breaking  news the Royal College of Nursing has  announced two further strikes in England  and Wales the RCN says if progress is  not made by the end of January its  members will strike again for 12 hours  on Monday the 6th and Tuesday the 7th of  February  but what we need to do is set to the  Prime Minister today please find a  resolution to this because no patient  deserves this and no member of nursing  staff deserves this to continue on any  longer we need to get around to a  negotiating table we need to do this  today and we need to be able to find a  way of averting this these strikes but  that's for Rishi sunak to really grasp  the nettle now and do as a matter of  urgency